- All right, let's cap this hour off
with something uplifting,
this is What I'm Liking.
(bright upbeat music)
Best friend, Shawn and Gerard
have set out on a mission
to get other men to up their kitchen game
so they can wine and dine their partners.
So they came up with a cooking series
that's in part culinary
and in part reflections on
life and all entertaining.
- I wanna know what you
got cooking for right now.
- I got nothing cooking, you gonna cook.
(Shawn laughs)
I'm gonna send you home
with a beautiful dessert
for your wife, a homemade
banana pudding, all right.
- I love that, and I know she will too.
- Yes. One thing that I
always tell everybody,
it's extremely important,
is you eat with your eyes.
You know what I mean?
You ever had somebody
make like delicious food
and they just kind of
plop it on the plate,
And it's like-
- Yeah, that's me.
(Shawn laughs)
- Right.
(audience applause)
- I love these guys so much, y'all,
that's probably why they were featured
on Peacock's "Baking It"
with Maya Rudolph and
Andy Samberg last year,
they're amazing.
We have them dialed in right now.
What's up Shawn, what's up Gerard.
(audience applause)
- Hey Kelly.
- I mean, I'm just gonna start with this,
if y'all ever wanna send
some banana pudding anywhere,
fine I'll take it.
Anyway, Shawn, tell us more
about how this all got started.
- Hey Kelly, thanks so much for having us.
Gerard and I've been
friends for about 40 years
and went to school together,
we pledged the same frat together-
- One nine!
(Kelly chuckles)
- Alpha Phi Fraternity Incorporated,
and around the time of COVID,
where we needed some COVID
relief, Gerard and I, our wives,
and a couple of other couples decided
to have these monthly
rotational dinners, right.
So all of our wives would be
cooking it up in the kitchen
and having a great time,
and the only guy that
would be doing the cooking
is Gerard at his house, right.
So Trisha, my wife, decided
to come up with a show
that would bring more guys in the kitchen
and Gerard would be leading that mission,
so we're excited about that.
(audience applause)
- Man, Trisha's a smart woman,
that's a smart woman.
Gerard, what about you,
what made you wanna do this?
- Oh, I just love cooking,
it's a passion project of mine, honestly.
And frankly, "Foods & Dudes"
is a different kind of show,
it's not your typical cooking show.
What we did was take this platform
and try to do something
a little bit different,
which is have conversations
that most men are not having,
especially in our community.
We really have to have these
conversations out loud,
so you'll see on the show, we
talk about education, finance,
building generational
wealth, raising our children,
relationships, all of those things.
And it's really, really important to us
to make sure that our viewers
and everybody gets to see a
different view of black men
doing something in the home.
We're preparing foods,
we're doing it with love,
basically we're doing it
great, that's the thing.
- Oh my God, those pictures,
those pictures up, food look so good,
your women are so lucky, oh my goodness!
All right guys, I'm liking
your post right now.
(soft bell ring)
(audience applause)
- Oh thank you, thank
you, oh (indistinct).
- That's not all, our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen at
"The Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like y'all.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000, $500 for each of you,
just for being cool.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- Now, thank you guys.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much for that.
- [Kelly] Keep it up,
we love watching you,
you are so funny.
And it's so cool
that you've got a solid
message going as well.
Thank you so much.